[Musica]
Io sono una persona normale Anzi meno
che normale ma esistono persone normali
Franco Basaglia diceva che visto da
vicino Nessuno lo è e io sono d'accordo
e aggiungo Per fortuna questo rende la
vita così interessante
appartengo alla Generazione X
invisibili la generazione inesistente la
nostra caratteristica sarebbe la tattica
del rinvio praticamente una sindrome di
Peter Pan anch'io confesso ne sono stata
affetta ma non per una mancanza di
aspirazione al contrario Forse per un
eccesso di potenzialità Infatti Quelli
come me cresciuti tra gli anni 80 e 90
avevano la percezione di poter fare in
ogni momento quello che volevano
scegliere ogni strada tutte le porte
erano aperte Potevi essere quello che
volevi essere soprattutto se era un
eclettico come me ovvero una persona a
cui viene abbastanza bene tutto va bene
bene niente
il problema era capire cosa volevi
essere Ecco la mia storia possa
impossibile racconta come e quando sono
diventata Quello che dovevo essere
perché c'è un momento della vita Un
preciso momento A partire dal quale c'è
un prima e c'è un dopo allora il tempo
si divide in due c'è un prima e c'è un
dopo
quel momento per me è stato più o meno
14 anni fa Sono nel parcheggio polveroso
davanti all'istituto di medicina
nucleare della mia città e tengo in mano
una busta con dentro Un referto è una
scintigrafia dazn del mio cervello sono
abbastanza tranquilla è un po' di tempo
che sono micrografica e faccio fatica a
scrivere ma darò colpa al computer che
mi hai disabituata la penna e poi credo
che sia lo stress quindi quell'esame
L'ho fatto per sicurezza così
tiro fuori dalla busta un foglio e
dentro ci sono le immagini a colori del
mio cervello e poi le conclusioni si
evidenzia un danno a sistema
dopaminergico presinaptico a livello di
putamen traduzione morbo di Parkinson
penso impossibile nella mia famiglia non
ce l'ha mai avuto nessuno e io credo che
sia una malattia ereditaria e poi ho 39
anni non è una malattia delle persone
anziane morbo di Parkinson idiopatico
giovanile capita sempre più spesso
una notizia del genere In effetti ti
ferma il tempo e lo divide in due c'è un
prima pieno di un futuro in cui tutto
ancora possibile e c'è un dopo doccia
solo un presente che ti costringe ad
essere e a fare E vi assicuro che forse
questo non è così male
all'epoca lavoravo come avvocato
penalista e uno studio a Firenze e
giravo tutta Italia per lavoro facevo
l'avvocato come lo fanno gli avvocati e
invece dal punto di vista il malato è il
lavoro più bello del mondo perché in
fondo tutto quello che finisce in
tribunale è un po' come se fosse il
frutto di una patologia sociale e se tu
sei malato
sei più portato all'empatia e vivi la
vita degli altri e ogni gesto diventa un
gesto eroico con queste nuove condizioni
non potevo rimanere a Firenze troppe
scrivanie e poi volevo tornare dalla mia
famiglia che stava massa e quindi sono
andata a fare l'avvocato di provincia
devono schernito Vai a difendere i Ladri
di polli invece ammazza sono stata
Antigone e non è poco i miei assistiti
erano gli ultimi degli ultimi
extracomunitari tossicodipendenti
zingari malati di mente detenuti più di
queste categorie insieme ma detenuti
soprattutto Sì perché in carcere
funziona tutto col Passaparola per caso
mi era capitato di essere nel corridoio
del tribunale di sorveglianza di Genova
mentre cercavano un difensore con una
nomina Come si dice in gergo 97 quarto
comma d'ufficio il detenuto chiedeva la
detenzione domiciliare per motivi di
salute perché aveva il Parkinson anch'io
nessuno sapeva che io ce l'avessi Ma
naturalmente l'udienza è andata
benissimo da allora sono diventata un
esperto del diritto dell'esecuzione
penale con diritto cadetto perché a
parte che è molto tecnico Può apparire
noioso mentre in realtà è molto
interessante ma non ci si guadagna nulla
io però nelle mie condizioni non avevo
fame di soldi avevo fame di vite e lì di
vite ce n'erano moltissime sconvolgenti
impossibili per me e loro le
condividevano con me per la prima volta
in vita mia ho sentito di essere
esattamente dove doveva essere
apparentemente era una femmina alfa ma
in realtà erano marginale nascosto a una
malata come loro perché la mancanza di
libertà qualsiasi cosa tu abbia fatto è
un popolo una malattia e forse si
avvertiva tant'è che il primo ad
accorgersi è stato proprio un detenuto e
poi dopo poco lo sapevano tutti il
fenomeno Si chiama radio carcere però
malgrado questo spopolavoro forse
proprio per questo volevano tutti me
perché l'ottavo per loro come l'ottavo
contro la mia malattia quella differenza
che mentre la mia malattia sapevo che
non potevo curarla pensavo che loro in
qualche modo potessero guarire e anche
se non era vero il fatto che io ci
credesse loro faceva bene non ero Madre
Teresa ne ero una dama di carità e loro
non erano Santi Ma chi lo è avevo
semplicemente capito qual era il mio
ruolo e lo vivevo era un advocatus
siamo quasi Allora sempre in quel
periodo era chiaro che in questo
contesto le cose non potessero andare
avanti a lungo e perché troppo impegno
poi la malattia continuava ad andare
avanti e me l'aspettavo Sono andata in
Burnout ma non per loro perché in
effetti qualsiasi cosa venisse da loro
faceva parte del gioco ma perché ogni
anticone ha un creonte e poi mi sono
anche rotto un Calcagno e quindi sono
stato praticamente quattro mesi chiusa
in casa è stato allora che ho cominciato
a dipingere in modo sistematico ho
sempre disegnato ho sempre disegnato ma
è una cosa diversa a dipingere perché ci
si sporca le mani
Inoltre c'è tutto la tensione tra te e
il colore la forma che si sente Credo
tra te il colore perché i colori se te
li fai da solo vengono un po' Come
vengono come vogliono loro intendo dai
colori fondamentali tu decidi che vuoi
fare un colore in realtà ne viene un
altro E tu devi decidere Allora se
accettare quello che viene o continuare
a cercare quello che volevi tu ma spesso
Ha ragione lui il colore e così con le
forme soprattutto se tu hai una mano che
trema o che è rigida Allora tu immagini
vedi una forma ne viene un'altra estate
decidere che fare è un po' come nella
vita se spingere oppure lasciar andare
il flusso e potremmo anche in questo
caso non essere male
e ora devo partire ho cominciato
trasformando dei legni del mare in pesci
colorati basta trovare l'occhio la coda
e il pesce praticamente è fatto la cosa
che mi diverte è che tutti quelli che
hanno visto i miei amici tutti ma molti
di quelli che hanno visto il mio pesci
non riescono più ad andare alla spiaggia
senza vedere dei pesci nei legni ormai
diventa un pezzo mentale e la cosa
invece che mi fa più piacere quando mi
dicono che ho trasformato della materia
inerte in qualcosa di vivo che è sempre
un atto di creazione che credo faccia
bene a tutti Poi ho fatto centinaia di
ritratti quando vedo delle persone che
in qualche modo mi intrigano Anche
semplicemente nei momenti di noia guardo
i visi li divido in linea e si respira
dentro il respiro serve per prendere
quel qualcosa che fa ritratto quindi
cercare di prendere l'anima perché mi
ritratti spesso non assomigliano In
effetti si chiamano ritratti che
ritrattano anche qui restano parte
dell'avvocato certe volte addirittura
prendono la stessa persona ma è più
vecchia o più giovane ma devo dire che
quando era al centro lo stesso prendo
qualcosa è talmente intimo che sono
costretto a regalarlo Infatti la maggior
parte dei ritratti Gli ho regalati è
tutto un inverso di visi che mi
circondano in qualche modo nei centrico
in un rapporto uno a uno
un po' come le passanti di Bressan De
Andrè e vanno Ma ci sono sempre parenti
più cariche appunto il semplice passanti
e questo è un rapporto tra me e ogni
singolo individuo che è capitato nella
mia vita se voi immaginate nella vostra
vita le costellazioni di un individuo
che avete incrociato
mentre il mio rapporto con gli altri
come relazioni in parte di un tutto non
erano umani però sono già passati
c'erano prima erano umani sono dei corpi
intrecciati che a formare dei rami si
chiamano rami umani proprio perché
l'idea mi è venuta da prima a guarda' un
ramo di Glitch in cui sembrava che
tralci formassero il corpo intrecciati
una gamba diventa un braccio ma così
nella vita degli uomini siamo in qualche
modo tutti legati e nei rami umani mi
vendico con la malattia perché lì mi
muovo come non riesco più a muovermi
quindi esploro le relazioni ci sono
delle relazioni che per me naturalmente
ora sono più limitate e ci sono dei
movimenti Come ballare o nuotare che i
rami fanno per me e poi ci sono le pare
idolie la paredonia è quel fenomeno
psichico credo per cui guardando le
nuvole banalmente ci si vedono degli
animali o delle forme definite il gioco
delle macchie Insomma il roshcraft Come
si chiama il test Ecco io lo faccio col
legno Praticamente con materia viva
osservo le tavole di legno e dentro ci
Cerco delle forme e quando ora
pareidoria quindi da poco continua
secondo un'idea mi si forma man mano
oppure seguendo la linea naturale di una
della capitale a mano è un bellissimo
stato questo perché anche questo caso
c'è tutto un lasciarsi andare È un
condurre è un gioco che tu fai con te
stesso appunto fra lasciar andare e
condurre e seguire il legno devo dire
che Poi onestamente mi sono resa conto
che quello che viene fuori che non so
mai cosa uscirà prima di tutto questo è
la porta delle anime che ho fatto è un
paese calabrese è influenzato da quello
che tu metti dentro da quello che
respiri nell'aria dal tuo stato
psicologico in quel momento per cui poi
capisce in fondo Che cos'è e ti senti
veramente nel famoso flusso quando lo
fai
Allora devo dire che ora non riesco più
a fare l'avvocato ma dipingo dipingere
mi fa sentire viva e non solo il mio
riscatto contro la malattia sento di
essere arrivata a fare a essere quello
che dovevo essere mi fa fatica ma quando
dipingo dimentico la mia malattia e
stranamente credo che la tensione
comunque traspare e si veda non molti
dicono che per gli insegnanti sono
portati a un particolare rapporto con
l'arte ammesso che possa definire
l'artista e i colori e io non so se nel
mio caso ci sia un rapporto causa
effetto così netto cioè sia l'avvocato
avrei detto la cosa prova controfattuale
ma sicuramente è stata l'occasione se
non la causa diretta perché diversamente
non credo che avrei dipinto molti non in
questo modo non in modo sistematico e
furioso come dire molti mi considerano
una persona coraggiosa Io non credo che
sia assolutamente coraggio il coraggio
Sarà che la possibilità di scegliere io
non ho scelta sono solo
appassionata morbosamente viva
[Applauso]
[Musica]